ladies and gentlemen boys and girls and
children
of all ages we are one month away
from the adventure of a lifetime the
epic
summer movie going event known as
jungle cruise you guys are excited we
are so excited
the timing of this movie uh getting
released uh couldn't be better as we are
all
trying to get on the other side of covid
and everyone
is going back to the movie theaters it's
an exciting time
so ladies and gentlemen i give you the
newest the greatest
and the latest trailer for jungle cruise
with myself
and my co-star uh uh
what's her uh what's her name essa
every what is it actually i know what it
is it's rhetorical
hey
ladies and gentlemen enjoy jungle cruise
trailer with myself
and ethel brunt in theaters around the
world
in one month enjoy
of all the jungle cruises you could take
in the amazon this one is undoubtedly
the cheapest but also the most thrilling
heads up coming through
look out
marauders
natives
ladies and gentlemen the moment you've
all been waiting for
the backside of water
steve's wonder of the world
anjana frankie boy mr nila please don't
call me that i'm going to keep your
engine
i got my money then you'll get it back
frank gives me money
[Music]
please go away i have a lot of money
we're headed up river to agreement
cristal
i gotta be honest it's not a fun
vacation
but you're gonna beg me to turn back
10 000 to bring you there live dead it's
15 000.
why should i pay more dead
dead i'd have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady
here we go
[Music]
uh
[Music]
it's impossible
hey guys oh i am so excited to bring you
the new
and actual trailer to our extraordinary
film disney's jungle
cruise i am so sorry about earlier
something very weird happened um it was
like this
rogue trailer this this uh this
desperate delusional sad trailer air
that bears no relation to the film that
we made
um it was like it was like how can i say
it was like the trailer had lost its
mind
that's what it feels like it feels like
it's lost its mind so so here we are
we're gonna rectify that right now and
the birds are out for you the animals
are out to celebrate this moment this is
it this is the true to life
trailer of our extraordinary film that
follows my character
dr lily houghton she's like indiana
jones she is brave and fearless
and wild and she's brilliant-minded and
humble
and she's going to be the one to take
you down the amazon river
on this adventure of a lifetime oh
and there's this um there's a lovely
little up-and-comer in it um
drives the bow um oh what's his name
this is a problem you blink and you'll
miss him you know um dave
dave gobson that's his name
so here we are i'm thrilled that you're
about to see this my heart is
racing that you're going to see our film
so soon this is it this is disney's
jungle cruise
legend has it there is a tree in the
amazon that possesses unparalleled
healing powers
and that row head is the key to
unlocking it
hello uh just wanted you to know this
has been mislabeled
he's shipping outlets
we're headed up river to blagramas de
cristal we must secure our travel come
on
not a good time my brother and i are
looking for passage up river please go
away
i have a lot of money
if you believe in legends you should
believe in curses too
it's not a fun vacation well i'm not
here for a vacation
well you're gonna beg me to turn back
allow me to manage my own safety
oh god sorry frank sorry strong form
oh i got you
i got it i don't got it no no no no no
what can this say
just leave me alone that was a disaster
didn't go the way i planned
the myth is real
you